tv host flew ten thousand miles for an
exclusive interview with adele and she
cancelled it last minute because he
didn't listen to me
get to know who you're interviewing
black santas are appearing in u.s disney
parks this season for the first time so
history is being made adam's story will
cover that bill maher stands up to
stands up for dave chappelle to chris
cuomo's face blast trent of kids
choosing their gender this is not crazy
stuff that makes you a bigot and then
box antonio brown uh obtained alleged
fake cover 19 vaccine card from teammate
uh we'll cover that as well kyle
rittenhouse obviously we've got to cover
what happened his interview yesterday
with tucker tucker carlson comments were
made here was he coached he was coached
well uh adam uh uh didn't like an
analogy with michael jordan all these
other things that maybe we'll get into
but adam has a hard time with analogies
today adam's been a little bit off the
last few weeks but we'll help him out
we'll help him out a few weeks army army
bars vaccine refusers from promotions
and re-enlistment as deadline approaches
aoc says progressives help wasn't wanted
in virginia governor race not a single
person called us or asked us to email
mansion worries biden social spending
agenda costs too much new poll shows
that how much the country wants trump to
run again this is an adams story and
then beto o'rourke says texas governor
campaign won't be about biden slams
president on immigration interesting
okay so let's let's get let's start
let's start off with a very uh simple
story with adele and what happened with
adele on page four can you imagine like
you're planning this big interview okay
i'm gonna go interview adele and you're
telling your family friends i'm flying
out to interview adele
and you're interviewing getting ready to
interview her and they ask you um
have you listened to the album and you
say no so a tv host flew ten thousand
miles from an exclusive interview with
adele only to have it canceled after he
said he hadn't listened to her new album
this is an insider's story matthew doran
or duran come on
street the host of channel 7's the
weekend sunrise show flew to london from
sydney a journey of about 10 000 miles
on november 4th to interview adele and
her only album interview only the only
album interviewed with an australian
outlet during the interview when asked
by adele what he thought of the new
album duran said he hadn't listened to
it yet the singer was offended the
interview ran to completion
but sony which owns adele's music later
told channel 7 that it was withholding
the rights to the interview footage as a
result of doran's oversight several
reports said duran was subsequently
suspended by channel 7 but duran said
that he wasn't formally suspended but he
was off the air for one week so the
total package uh for the rise for dell's
interview footage which included access
to the video from oprah winfrey one
night only with adele cost the channel
cost channel seven ready 725
thousand dollars
matt what do you think about this is it
pb you've had me interview people on
behalf of php you had me interview bo
jackson you had him in general uh a mad
dog mattis which you crushed by the way
both of them i appreciate that but i'm
following your model because every time
i see you do an interview i see you
consume content i see you read books i
see you have your team gives you a
package and before you're about to
interview some so just watching your
behavior before you interview somebody
it's just doing your homework
listen we're no
professional journalist but it's just
common sense if you're going to
interview something and a company is
investing
750 000 and your career could be made
because it is in and you fail to do the
basic thing in terms of getting to know
the person that you're interviewing i
think that's a
improper isn't it it was definitely
something that uh i'd be professionally
embarrassed about if i wasn't prepared
to interview somebody i asked rogan i
said rogan how do you prepare for
interviews he said some of them i do
some of them i don't some of them i just
go in some of them i consume a lot of
books and stuff to get in and some of
them i just go in because i want to have
a conversation with them but
rogan didn't ask spotify to pay adele
seven hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars if a company you work for is
paying somebody that you're gonna
interview 725 yeah you better take care
of that i mean you you're you're i don't
know that that is irresponsible to me
it's also not like some esoteric indie
artist that like you know their agent
just shoved in front of you and you got
to like feign interest in this person
like oh yeah no
loved your uh your hit song on tick tock
there 19 year old no like you know like
yeah i remember when bad baby was coming
out and they were trying to make her
like a uh don't you talk trash about bad
babies buddy danielle we're going to try
across the table try to catch them
outside
outside and every talk show she went on
was like we love you and your mute who
was it yeah you're like yeah no you're
great and you were raised really well
yeah for sure
they all had to figure out a way to get
through this is adele yeah this is a
land-wide moment hello this is hello
dude
i love adele so much i just i was just
trying to show tyler my first quote
unquote viral video the first video that
got me anywhere on the internet was me
with funny or die as adele i was dressed
as adele for one of your daughters you
gotta be kidding me yes you've got you
that's me
this is when it was a little bit bigger
she lost a lot of weight yeah
so the uh that's beautiful yeah yeah you
know thank you thank you man it's it's
gorgeous you know i'm i'm uh i'm the
world's most most beautiful uh
system yeah what do you think about this
what do you think about it we gotta give
look we all know adele i don't think we
need to listen to her new album to ask
her a couple questions we know
the biggest thing she's doing she's
dating lebron's agent these days rich
paul did you know about that of course
okay that's a little bit bigger news but
this guy he came from australia sydney
australia flew to london yeah do you
familiar with what's going on with in
australia these days they've been on
lockdown yeah like craig this guy's just
excited to get the frick out of the
house for the first time in two years
he gets out of town out of house and he
gets
packaged up resent back to sydney to
convict island i feel bad for this guy
should he have been more prepared if you
were on a plane for 20 hours
and it never even occurred to you to
listen to my album hello i'd be pissed
off too go get yourself some fish
imagine imagine somebody comes to
interview you pat they come from all the
ipad i'm a huge fan i come to interview
i'm i'm coming all the way from
australia awesome dude sits down so
patrick what's your last name enjoy you
enjoy all your work what do you do like
i could see you you know she could be a
family yeah
by the way i want to show you so sunday
night gerard's at the house you guys
left very early like 1 30 whatever the
time was but uh we're we're having
conversations we
originally there's movies i want to get
the kids prep for we were watching
gladiator a couple scenes they probably
shouldn't watch but it is what it is
that night i made
but but i show him a clip of the rock
when he showed up to rnc republican
national convention in 2000 which i
don't know if you know this or not and
he was interviewed and a similar
situation happened as with adele so if
you can make this this is c-span make it
bigger first make it bigger first so
c-span you can show because it's
taxpayers money pay and c-span watch
what happens when this guy's
interviewing the rock and he has no clue
in the rockets and the rock gets pissed
listen
looks like steve is successful let's try
there we go
this is an adele situation here on the
all this crowd around you and i had no
idea who you are who is the rock oh it's
okay well i didn't know you either so i
guess we're kind of even uh who is the
rock the rock is the most electrifying
man in sports entertainment the wwf
champion brock is here representing the
people being the people's champion as
well and again not necessarily to try
and sway votes towards the republican
candidate or the democratic candidate
for that matter as much as he is just
here to uh you know to make sure that
that the 22 million viewers the rock
reaches everything 22 million views you
have to put it there what do you think
about this this crowd stays in character
the whole time yeah luckily we have a
spokesperson for the rock
what did pitbull say pitbull said you
look like rocks
i told him on the walmart target version
at your birthday party i always thought
you were tongan or simone or something
at your birthday party when you told me
you were filipino i was like what are
you like two filipinos and an overcoat
or something like that you're the
biggest filipino on earth you should be
the starting center on the olympic day
well nowadays what are you lifting
nowadays by what are you hitting
nowadays are you squatting like four or
five plates what are you hitting bench
what's what's some of the numbers you're
doing right yeah uh with reps i mean i'm
doing a 415 deadlifts you know repping
the 315 on bench and uh you know that
you know uh i'm not doing any squats but
i do the leg press yeah so they got the
leg press machine you put both racks
yeah you can rack them i think i'm up to
15 plates on 15 racks yeah 15 45s 3 15
45 yeah three 315 on the on the bench
press for long arms that's real good
yeah so if lizzo ever lays on top you
can get out so that's 30 plates total
yeah yeah yeah exactly right
so so and i think what we're all
agreeing with here with the story of
adele is the fact that
also adele is classic classic of there's
no such thing as ugly you're just broke
would you say adele is the michael
jordan of something
would that totally like offend you if i
think
it's one of those things where in my
humble opinion amazing voice like the
voice itself yeah
but if i'm if i have a hundred songs to
listen to to get me in a good mood
adele's not i'm she's gonna make me cry
oh hello 25 25. it's just it's just it's
not for me well my generation but gerard
dresses up as a dell for fun apparently
so maybe that's a little more your vibe
i got a great banter i asked him this
morning with his favorite workout song
is i'm posting something an idea give me
a workout song you were excited you know
he says i'm thinking like intercepted
yeah
mario he says barbie girl
what say something about it
okay inclined upper chest i saw i saw
this man sing frozen
on stage at a karaoke at a karaoke event
so gerard's very much in touch with his
feminine side so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]